Speaker 1: Michael Knowles, formerly a
sort of third stringer for The Daily Wire,
who has rocketed to stardom on the back of
Anti-transgender ism, is now pretending that
words have no meaning and that we don't have
video of the things that he said. Let me back up
and explain it to you. The right has started to
really be titillated by anti-trans rhetoric and
the wilder that the rhetoric is, the more the
right wing cheers and stands and loves it. And
we've seen this at CPAC over the last few years.
The biggest applause lines at CPAC are anti-trans
stuff. When Ted Cruz said my pronouns are kiss my
ass, the crowd went nuts last year. And similarly,
when Michael Knowles recently called for the
eradication of transgenderism, the crowd loved it.
The problem is that when you talk about the
eradication of transgenderism, it's natural
to wonder, well, what the hell happens to
the transgender people? Are you calling
for genocide or what exactly are you calling for?
And the blowback has been severe against Michael
Knowles. So he is now pretending that words
have no meaning. He went on the Tucker Carlson
program last night. Of course, he got the hero's
welcome from most of right wing media. And again,
this is why they do this stuff. Matt Walsh,
another right winger, has done incredibly well
with the anti-trans stuff. So Michael Knowles got
jealous. He wanted to jump on the bandwagon and
it's sort of working. But here he is claiming,
oh, the left is putting words in my mouth.
Speaker 3: I've been called all sorts
of nasty things by the liberal press.
Speaker 1: It's been nasty, nasty.
Speaker 3: So I tend to expect everything.
But I have to admit being accused of genocide did
take me by surprise. That seemed extreme even for
the fake news media. And I think it surprised a
lot of lawyers as well. The Daily Beast and the
Huffington Post and Rolling Stone and a number of
other outlets all spread this lie about me. They
just put words into my mouth. They did never said,
You heard exactly what I said. I said that for the
good of these people in particular, so presumably
I don't want to murder them. And I talked about
an ideology in particular. I'm not talking about
eradicating any human beings. I'm talking about
an ideology here. They said that I wanted to
commit genocide and I said, this is a libel.
This is actual libel. You know, the libel laws
in the United States have quite a high threshold
to actually sue. This meets that threshold.
Speaker 1: It does not. He is not going to
collect a single dollar that I can assure you.
Speaker 3: I think that unless the news editors
at The Daily Beast and Rolling Stone
and Huffington Post and all the rest,
unless they're completely illiterate, they
lied intentionally. And I think their lawyers
called them and said, change the headline or
you're going to get sued into oblivion. Right?
Speaker 1: Well, the problem is we have the
video. We have the video from his podcast and
we have the video from CPAC. And he says, we must
eradicate transgenderism now. Oh, but David, he's
not saying kill trans people. No, I understand.
I understand. Let's listen to what he said first.
Speaker 2: There can be no middle way in dealing
with transgenderism. It is all or nothing.
If transgenderism is true, if men really can
become women, then it's true for everybody
of all ages. If transgenderism is false as it is,
if men really can't become women, as they cannot,
then it's false for everybody to. And if
it's false, then we should not indulge it.
Especially since that indulgence requires taking
away the rights and customs of so many people. If
it is false, then for the good of society, and
especially for the good of the poor people who
have fallen prey to this confusion, transgenderism
must be eradicated from public life entirely.
Speaker 1: Eradicate transgenderism
from public life. And then here he is
on his podcast a couple of days before CPAC.
Speaker 3: That I called to ban transgenderism
entirely. I made the point that if you want
if you want women to have their own bathrooms,
if you think women ought to be able to have their
own locker rooms and not have to look at gigantic
gross men. Well, little girls are getting
changed. If you want any of those things.
You have to ban transgenderism
entirely. It's not enough to say, well,
you have to wait until you're 12 or whatever.
Speaker 1: All right. So ban it eradicated. Fine.
So let's go through this piece by piece. This is
a way of getting attention and it's working. And
he's getting it. He's getting the hero's welcome
from the right wing. He's been treated like a
martyr, like a victim, getting tons of interviews
and on and on. Succeeded. No problem. What you
have to understand, if we want to be reasonable
people, is that there really is no way to separate
eradicating transgenderism from an attack on
transgender people. Now, I am not making the
argument that he is saying kill trans people. I'm
not saying he's saying that. But what you have to
understand is there's no practical separation,
because if you ban the thing that makes a trans
person trans, which means being able to exist in
the world with the gender identity that they have
determined is right for them, you are eliminating
trans people in terms of what their identity is.
And so you don't literally have to kill them
to eradicate them. And of course, these are
the types of postmodern semantic linguistic games
that the right loves to say the left plays, but
they themselves are better at playing them than
anybody else. And again, like I said yesterday,
would anybody accept this explanation if someone
had said we must eradicate Judaism? No, no, no,
no. I don't want anything to happen to the Jews,
just completely eradicate Judaism. We would all be
reacting the same way. Most of us are reacting
to the trans thing with the exception of some
of these loons on the right. So it's working.
It's getting him the attention. The question
is what's the end game? And quite frankly,
I don't know. But for now, he's getting the
hero's welcome on Tucker and elsewhere. And
that's exactly what this was intended to do.